Are you curious about the quality of your vision?
Take a look at this picture, who do you see?
If you are a natural distance from the screen and your unit is visible you are seeing Albert Einstein
However, if you see Marilyn Monroe you should consider wearing glasses or lenses
Are you wearing your glasses now? Try to take it off and the picture may change or if your Lord someone ask him what he sees?
In fact, this effect may be seen by anyone if we change the dimension or size of the image
If it is far away it is likely to see Marilyn Monroe where our eyes only capture the outlines of the image from afar
But when you approach the picture, you see the exact details of Einstein
We promise that we did not change anything digitally, just stop this video now and try to stay away from the computer screen
The odds are, the picture will change and at a different distance from your friends because our eyes are all slightly different
The farther you stand and the farther Einstein sees, the better your eyes may be
You can get the same effect by partially closing your eyes to blur the image
So what's going on? Well, this picture is an example of a hybrid image.
Where the low accuracy of one of the two pictures is merged with
High resolution picture of the other, however
Depending on how well our eyes are matched and captured
Antonyms your eye will pick up only certain details
Close-up we are generally able to see minute details like Einstein's mustache
And encourage it, but with increasing dimension
Or if your vision is weak and this creates a distorted image in the first place
Your ability to capture details will disappear instead. You will only see public profiles
Like the shape of the mouth, nose and hair
What makes him look like Marilyn Monroe
Do you like to fool your mind with illusion? We've compiled a playlist of our favorite videos
Which you can see by clicking on the screen
Do not forget to follow us on Facebook, Instagram and Twitter
Subscribe to more weekly science videos